i could put more guys on the place if
that's what you're thinking open for
business what you're doing to help the
little guy it's incredible i'm just
getting started
i just need you to know that i know it
wasn't me cliff sounds like money okay
great
there's proving and there's knowing is
that what's going on is there more to
this line that bill oakley delivered
last week because howard is going to be
in the knowing category as far as jimmy
being behind what cliff is confronting
him about in this teaser soon is it
about him not being able to prove it and
that making him go crazy or look like
he's going crazy there has to be
something more but it's also kind of fun
that it's not obvious hey guys pete here
today i'm gonna preview better call saul
season six episode five it's a short
teaser i'm gonna break that down there's
only a couple of promo photos this week
but i'll be going over some of the stuff
we've seen in other teasers and how all
of this ties into the previous episode
and i'll say that if any of that stuff
sounds like spoilers then this video
probably isn't for you and with that out
of the way let's just jump into it this
episode is titled black and blue and the
official description reads while
business booms for jimmy the vice
tightens on the cat and mouse game
between gus and lalo there are several
shots of jimmy getting things together
with all these newfound clients and i
think in some of these interactions we
see bob odenkirk playing the character a
lot more like breaking bad than what
we're used to seeing and better call
saul lalo is name checked without
appearing in the trailer but the mention
of the cat and mouse game would indicate
his return is imminent are we gonna find
out where he is are we gonna see him or
will we get something like an end of
episode reveal i would like to find out
what he's up to and we do have a lot of
teaser footage that hasn't shown up yet
but either way in this teaser we can see
that he's influencing things that other
people are doing the episode title being
black and blue is a translation of the
breaking bad episode that was titled
negro e azul that one opened with a
teaser that was a narco currito music
video about a gringo boss taking over
albuquerque with his blue meth black hat
blue meth and i mean if they went that
way again with a song about gus and lalo
i'd be into it but overall it's not the
most eventful episode of that series but
it is the one that came right before
saul goodman's first episode is that a
clever nod does that mean the office
will be open and jimmy will be full soul
mode in the next episode we'll have to
wait and see as we approach episode 5
one thing that's become evident is that
they're trying to make the promo clips
misleading i'm still going to look at
them and break them down but it is
something to keep in mind the episode 5
trailer opens with kim putting a chair
under the door handle for a little extra
security and then we see them on the
couch together looking a little scared
and saul says thank god he's dead the
first thing you think of here is that
he's talking about lalo the only problem
with that is that kim found out that
lalo probably wasn't dead in the last
episode so if she's putting a chair
under the door she's worried but is she
gonna come clean with him or are they
talking about something else completely
chuck mcgill is also dead he could be
talking about him here they could be
talking about how he would never approve
of what he's doing with this new office
and his new practice and all these new
clients but that feels a little
disconnected there's a shot of the
future super lab where construction has
been halted ever since verner went on
the run with lalo out there you can't
imagine that they're actually starting
to work on it again and mike tells him
that he can put more guys on the place
if that's what he's thinking so you have
to imagine that gus is worried that this
is going to be discovered which wouldn't
be an easy thing to do outside of mike
and his little circle inside gus's
operation there's only a few people that
even know that this job was going on the
germans that worked for werner and lydia
at madrigal if they're there the
question is if something happened or if
they're just discussing their strategy
i'm in the camp of people who believe
that he's probably looking into what was
going on with the construction the
little bit that he got off earner on the
phone and where that takes him but
there's nothing here that we can point
to and say oh okay i see what's
happening that's how that's all
connected as a reminder the german
workers were hooded and transported
there so they never knew where the
location was even if lalo found them
they wouldn't know much about the
details in our live stream discussion it
seemed like some people thought that he
might be headed to chile to learn more
about gus's past but i was under the
impression that the cartel already knew
about that and then the other thing i
saw was that some people thought he
might be looking into what's going on at
madrigal but i don't know what we've
seen so far that would lead him in that
direction there's a popular theory that
lalo will be somehow lured to this
location he'll be killed he'll be buried
down there and then that would change
how you see all those super lab scenes
in breaking bad he did mention the south
wall quite a lot and people have jumped
on that thinking he might be a part of
that wall before all is said and done as
far as we know he's nowhere near
albuquerque at this point though so
let's hope we see him and figure out
what's happening there there's just one
other shot of gus working at los pollos
and you see him have something like a
facial tick happen which means he looks
stressed and things have not cooled down
since the last episode there's just one
shot of kim where she's not with jimmy
she meets with viola who was her
assistant and she took her over to
swichard and coakley with her they meet
at the el camino dining room which seems
to be her home base and viola says what
you're doing to help the little guy it's
incredible kim responds that she's just
getting started and it looked like it
caught her off guard in the comments of
my last video i saw a lot of people who
thought that kim might change her mind
about this plan against howard now that
people are showing interest in this pro
bono practice idea that she has cliff
was interested in what she was doing he
might even be able to help her out but
my takeaway was that she was mildly
amused by that development while being
fully focused on carrying out their plan
i think that's who she is once she sets
her sights on something she goes for it
especially since she left her cushy job
there was a time when you would think
kim might make the sound decision for
the right reasons but i think that time
has passed i think they're trying to
abort their plan to go after kevin and
then jimmy turning the whole thing
around on her was the last time we'll
see her do something like that i think
her motivation goes deeper than just
wanting to have this pro bono practice
and personally i'd have a hard time
buying her just abandoning this current
path she's on i do imagine that the idea
of her having the choice to do it the
right way will add weight to what i
expect to be a tragic conclusion for her
story cliff is part of the world that
howard represents and since that
probably plays a part in her decision
making would she just throw in with him
he shows up in a parking lot where he
confronts howard saying i just need you
to know i know howard denies his
involvement saying it wasn't him and the
implication is that this is about wendy
being tossed out of the namaste mobile
this is where my misdirection censors
went off not to say that this is not
what this conversation is about but i do
wonder how cliff would react to howard
having a drug problem now that we know
about his son's struggles he might
actually be supportive of howard in his
time in need he might want him to get
help and the setup is pretty good
because you have to feel for howard who
has a solid alibi he knows he didn't do
this but because of the way they set
things up it would be hard for him to
get anyone to believe him cliff knows
what he's seen with his own eyes it's
not an actual trial where howard will be
able to call his therapist as a witness
it's just the thing that's really hard
to discredit alongside all the other
things that cliff already has on his
radar i mean it was common knowledge
around the yard that howard has a coke
problem there's just one other shot of
howard's license plate as his car backs
up in a hurry which makes me think that
they'll be continuing on to the next
step in their plan there's a shot of an
unknown character opening up a cabinet
that's filled with chemicals this
appears to be the same character from an
earlier teaser and if you look closely
you can see that one of the containers
is methylamine i don't know anything
about making crystal meth but as someone
who watched breaking bad i imagine that
being there means that this is related
to a cook who is cooking and why are
good questions that i don't have an
answer to this all seems a little
unrelated to what's happening at the
moment so i'm curious to see how this
fits in
i mentioned earlier how i thought that
bob odenkirk was playing this a little
bit more like saul and we see several
examples of this in the teaser we hear
him say open for business and opening
the door for a customer at his new strip
mall office location we see him get a
call on his signature bluetooth earpiece
saying sounds like money okay great and
in all of this you can see his enjoyment
of playing this part it's really clear
even from the little bit we see here you
can see that he's lit up from these new
developments we also see francesca
banging on the door of her future place
of employment there's a handwritten sign
on the door that reads saul goodman and
associates it looks like she's looking
for a job and when she goes inside she
learns that it's actually working for
her old boss jimmy mcgill who is now
going by saul he's getting his office
ready to go there was a shot in a
different teaser where he said that the
name saul goodman was to the law like
the name colonel sanders was to chicken
that all seems to be from the same
interaction and then there's just one
other shot of kim lighting a cigarette
in the apartment this and the one in the
beginning and the only two promo photos
they put out this week all appear to be
related to a couple of shots we haven't
seen yet from earlier teasers in one she
says you know what's coming next and in
the other she makes a punching motion
and says i'm saul goodman i fight for
you so not much more to say about this i
mean we see jimmy having a good time out
in the world being saul and then things
looking pretty heavy behind closed doors
perhaps it's lollow perhaps it's the
stress of whatever they're trying to
pull off either way i can't wait to find
out and to find out if this is gonna be
the boxing gym episode is this gonna be
the episode where we see lalo what he's
up to and to bring it back around to the
beginning i've been thinking that howard
figuring out that jimmy is behind what
they're doing is all part of the plan it
just seems obvious that he would be the
most likely suspect considering the
circumstances and i think these
characters are smart enough to factor
that into their plans considering i
don't think kim sticks around something
has to go wrong and that's where things
will get interesting one popular theory
that i keep seeing come up is that
howard will commit suicide as a result
of what they're doing and i'm not sold
on this idea i don't think there needs
to be an explanation as to where howard
is during breaking bad there's not much
overlap between the world of hhm and
walter white so i'm not sure he needs
such a dramatic conclusion that said the
idea seems to be popular and it's
something to consider in my mind there
are plenty of ways that things can go
sour for kim and jimmy even if they're
successful and howard wouldn't need to
be a casualty for it to hit hard when
this thing they've got going comes to an
end and i think that's a good place to
leave this video so let me know in the
comments what you're hoping to see what
you're hoping to find out and where you
think things are going please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already it
looks like we'll be doing the live
stream discussion every tuesday night at
9 00 pm now so i wanted to make that
announcement and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon